let's hear from people people in the
audience because without you I'm a guy
in a room with a microphone and
everybody is sad and everything is bad
you can uh call in Via Discord at
davidpackman.com
slash Discord and we are going to start
today with a very very special person
we're starting with Steve from the Bay
Area Steve welcome what's going on
and Steve is gone oh boy already having
a problem let's go to Tomas from my
birth city of Buenos Aires Tomas
bienvenido
oh boy
hello
Tomas you have a configuration problem
where whatever audio device you have
selected doesn't actually work because
you're unmuted
and we will give Tomas one last
opportunity to resolve
his audio issues
hmm people are telling me they can hear
Tomas so let's see maybe this is my
audio settings let's see if I can fix
that
uh
uh let's see here
Tomas are you with me
I am oh wow welcome welcome welcome that
was my fault I apologize
hello once again pleasure
um I'm not gonna ask you how you're
doing so
because you said not to thank you yeah
no need I'm doing fine today we don't
need everybody to ask me how I'm doing
tell me what's going on with the
currency these days in Argentina
when is it when is it ever different
we're doing badly got it and what at
this point is everybody operating on the
blue dollar
everyone's operating on just
not operating I guess okay fair fair
well what's on your mind today
um you know the whole uh Luciani thing
that's going on in Argentina no I have
not been following it
basically I don't know if you remember a
long time ago we had the
what's it called the prosecutor nissman
who killed himself supposedly supposedly
yes yeah
well there's a new prosecutor that is
going to prosecute Chris Christina oh
yes yes no I didn't know his name but I
have been following that yeah
and our president Alberto he said
I hope he doesn't kill himself like the
last one did right that would be really
sad if that happened on TV
uh he said that on on antenna right
yeah yeah I saw that it's completely
insane now you know I I have friends and
some of them I'm friends with on
Facebook who are christinitas they just
love Christina
they have been silent since this
happened now I'm sure that down there
some of them are being very loud but
like how are they defending this
basically there's like all of regolita
is just swarming with with like
krishnaristas and stuff like everyone's
just in the streets like all day long
but what's been the reaction to that
comment I hope he doesn't kill himself
it's ignored completely okay yeah that
makes sense that's very trumpian
actually
yeah it is it is do you think do you
think she's going to end up in prison in
all seriousness
I don't I don't think so probably not
right yeah it just doesn't seem like
they never do they never do exactly
exactly wow well
all right she did it would be there
would be like riots and stuff it would
absolutely right yeah you know Lindsey
Graham said if Trump gets indicted there
will be riots just imagine what will
happen if Christina ends up in prison
yeah people would a lot of people would
die yeah any new type of Empanada I
should be aware of
oh uh
oh that's interesting that's sort of
American isn't it it really is yeah it's
my favorite time now wow and it's just
like is it a normal hot dog or is it
like a nice sausage
no it's normal hot dog just cut up and
put it that's really sad it's really sad
to see Empanada culture go into the
direction of hot dogs
I mean it's delicious so oh God I can't
complain all right my friend well thank
you for the call
see ya thanks ciao that was geez that's
that's depressing the David packman
shows longest running sponsor is
blinkist the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils each of them
down into an explainer you can read or
listen to in 15 minutes blinkist also
condenses episodes of popular podcasts
into 15-minute explainers I've been
using blinkist for years to supplement
the books I read I love reading I I read
all the time but there's even more books
I don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkisconnect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below